So, passwords are hashed. Are you completely safe? No. Sorry to
lead you down this path. We have, we have more to
do. The problem is, there are, you know, a handful of
good hashing algorithms that people would use for this sort of
thing. You know, let's, let's, let's pretend we're using SHA-256, because
that's a pretty decent algorithm. If somebody were to go through
and create a mapping of every word to the hash of
that word. That would be a problem. because remember the whole strength
of this hashing problem is that it's really hard to
get from the hash to the plain text that led to
that hash. You know, to, if you have H of a,
you know, the hash of a. It's really hard to figure
out a. But if you've got already computed it for every
word, and all you have to do is you know compute
at once and create the inverse table. Once somebody has this
table of all this words computed once, they're done. You know,
if you created a mapping of you know the SHA-256 of
every word to the original word, all of a sudden you get,
you get a database of a bunch of SHA-256 passwords. You can
look up what the password is instantly. And this table has a
name. It's called a rainbow table. There are these things, these mappings,
these databases of a hash version of a password to the clear
text password, they exist. You can Google for a rainbow table for
a hash algorithm of your choice, you know, download that hash table
or, you know, download that mapping, turn it into a hash table and
you're good to go. There's a very simple way to get around this. You
may remember from our cookie approach, that all we have to do is
add in some secrets. But we don't want to add in the same secret over
and over again. Otherwise, you're basically
vulnerable to the same fairly similar technique.
So what we do instead is we use something called a salt. So in
our user table, we're storing our name, and we're storing a hash of
the password. Instead of storing just a
hash of the password, we're going to add.
A secret to it. It's similar to how we
did with the cookies except this is not really secret.
We're just going to say this hash is going to equal our
hashing function of the password plus salt. And this
salt, instead of, so this looks very similar to
what we did with the cookies. Right? We were using
HMAC and, and we had a password, and, and a
secret. Except the salt is just. It's just some random
characters we make up. You can make them up
and you store them in the hash field, in the
clear. So, in this field, we'll, we'll actually have
the hash. Now this abbreviated as H and right along
with it we'll have the salt and what this
does is, is this prevents this quick lookup from working
because all of a sudden we've added this these random
strings. So, instead of saying hash of a equals a,
we have to figure out what's, well what's hash of
a you know, plus the salt. And all of a sudden
that table's completely invalid. So, when you store a user. You
know this is the type of algorithm you can do. Now,
outside of this class I want you to think very hard
about doing this yourself. You know as with all crypto you
should probably not being implementing it yourself because people have thought
this through. They have done it securely and you are not
yet qualified to do so. I want you to think very
hard. About using third party libraries, because a lot of third party
libraries also get this wrong. So, basically, think very hard. You
want to get this right. There's a couple more things I'll tell you
to look for when you're evaluating a third party library, but
a lot of them really screw this up, and you don't want to
just trust them blindly, so. You know, I'd rather you do
it yourself knowing how to do it than you trust a third
party library blindly, but the best knowledge you
can have is what to look for in
a third party authentication library. Let's go ahead
and implement some naive functions for, you know, hashing
and salting a password so you can see how the, the flow works. And then we'll
talk about some of the things you should
look for when you're evaluating you know somebody's approach.